okay so thank you all for coming today
I'm going to be talking about static
frame and immutable alternatives to
pandas all right so you might first
consider why you need an alternative to
pandas well to answer that question I
really have to talk about my work in the
context of my work I produce production
back-end financial systems
I am the implement libraries and API is
that need to last years and I not often
doing ad hoc data exploration in fact I
am often producing these production
systems so I favor packages with minimal
additional dependencies consistent
stable api's with low upgrade costs and
interfaces that reduce opportunities for
air so I've been using sorry I'm
confused here okay so I've been using
pandas in production since 2013 so I've
been using it for a long time it has
contributed greatly to my productivity
it provides pretty critical
functionality for working with tabular
data for processing grouping and
extracting that data an efficient column
addition in fact we use data frames very
frequently in data pipelines where we're
using addition of columns as logging
incremental transformations of data as
we proceed through the table but from
time to time I wonder if pandas is
really the right tool for my work and in
fact I found that in many cases it's not
so let's consider what I need in an
alternative so the core requirements of
an alternative is that we have pandas
like approaches to selecting and
transforming one and two-dimensional
labelled data this is really a critical
feature as well as robust handling of
missing data and heterogeneous types
these are features of pandas that we all
take for granted and are extremely
valuable
we need numpy level performance and for
my work I need to process data that fits
in memory I don't have big data concerns
working with in memory generally works
fine for me now going further than those
core requirements we can look at some
sort of extended requirements that we'll
talk about as we move forward I'm
looking for more narrow and consistent
interfaces tighter
with numpy and immutable data the value
and importance of all these I will
discuss as we proceed so static frame is
that alternative it is a Python 3
wrapper around numpy and I say that
explicitly because I'm not trying to do
what numpy does I don't have the time or
the resources for that I'm really
wrapping numpy there's no Python to
support and the only dependency at this
time is numb pine it borrows but narrows
many components of the panda's API it is
not a drop-in replacement some some
things are similar but many things are
different it's built around immutable
numb PI's arrays I've been developing it
since May of 2017 the first release was
in May 2018 of this year so that's what
we're the core thing we're looking for
there's some things we're not looking
for a static frame will not be the most
powerful and flexible tool that is that
is not my goal
pandas has the broader goal of becoming
the most powerful and flexible
open-source data analysis manipulation
tool available in any language that's a
fantastic goal and that has provided
tremendous benefit to the Python
community but that power and flexibility
comes at a cost and you know sometimes
that cost it makes it challenging to
produce these more narrow interfaces
that I'm looking for now you may not
need an alternative and that's perfectly
fine for many tasks pandas is still the
best tool it has outstanding performance
it has a breadth of support and
integration so for many tasks pandas
will of course be exactly the right
thing for what you're doing
however for production libraries and API
is an alternative maybe better of course
with static frame you can easily go back
and forth so I have methods to go to and
from pandas so you can dabble and use a
mixed environment if that's your
preference okay so after covering a
little bit of the motivation of how
static frame came to be I'm going to
focus on some of the differences and I'm
going to spend a bit of time on
immutability because that's one of the
key differences and that's really one of
the key things that drove my exploration
in the creation of static frame and then
we'll talk about a few other differences
look at performance and finish up so
let's talk about immutability concerns
about immutable
we are not a new concern in the classic
structure and interpretation of computer
programs from 1979 which I know you have
all have read the authors point out that
you know assignment as a type of
mutation they point out that in contrast
a functional programming programming
that makes extensive use of assignment
is known as a period of programming in
addition to raising complications about
computational models programs written in
imperative style are susceptible to bugs
that cannot occur in functional programs
this is often mentioned in passing but
this is a very nice extinct statement of
that fact so how do we avoid mutation in
Python well we can use native and
mutable containers we have a few of them
in Python or just a few we have a tupple
and a frozen set that's pretty much it
the series in frame however are types of
mappings and we do not actually have any
immutable mappings in Python the frozen
dict peph for 16 was rejected and so
we're left without any immutable
mappings in the standard Python library
of course named tupple is kind of a
mapping but it doesn't support arbitrary
keys so that doesn't really count
so how do we avoid mutation in Python
well we can use these native immutable
containers or we can use mutable
containers but always make defensive
copies that is we have to accept that we
don't know if other references have a
handle to our objects so we make a copy
of them a defensive copy before making
any changes
so that's mutation in Python but what
about avoiding mutation in numpy well
numpy starts out pretty much already
there in that we have a raise of fixed
size and fixed type we cannot change the
size of a numpy array we cannot change
its type but array values are mutable by
default well it turns out we can get
around this by an excellent feature of
numpy in my example here I'm going to
create a simple numpy array this is
going to be a range of 10 integers and
I'm going to mutate a value I'm going to
set index 3 to 300 and we see the array
has been mutated now we can mutate an
array to make it immutable by setting
the writable flag to false once we've
done this
if we try to change the value in the
array we get an exception and that's
pretty nice because with this we can
build immutability in static frame numpy
provides the core immutability it is
circumvented I just showed you how to
turn it on and off but this is not about
security this is about coding style and
a coding style that reduces
opportunities for errors so all
operations in static frame return new
containers of immutable arrays there are
no in-place operations and many
lightweight containers can share
references to the same immutable data
this is one of the huge benefits of this
approach is that I can have blocks of
numpy arrays shared across multiple
frames without ever doing a copy because
they cannot be mutated now the core
classes within static frame are also
immutable the attributes on those
classes are not mutable the they are
defined with slots so all the classes
are slotted you can't add arbitrary
attributes series and frame classes are
immutable in both dimensions we do have
a special class called frame geo which
is a grow only frame that adds columns
to a frame so you can grow only you can
add columns to a frame and that's sort
of kind of this mixture of mutability
and immutability but is one that's quite
useful so in order to really get a sense
of why immutability is so valuable we
really need to look at an example
because understanding why immutability
is important really takes looking at
architecture of code so I'm gonna give
you a very contrived and a little bit
silly example please bear with me but
through this example hopefully we'll be
able to see why immutability is so
important so we have a system that
produces those giant vinyl banner signs
right it's a fully automated system that
prints out these giant vinyl banners
it's very exciting
multiple engineers work into this system
and produce routines that map jobs to
colors they're not exciting banners they
just have one color these jobs are
submitted to printers via frame where
each row is a print job and
each road defines the color and a
printer to print to now these are going
to end up as columns in a big table so
there's a common API that our engineers
use called a VB Engine and this provides
some utilities like a mapping of colors
to CMYK values numerous frames from
engineers are concatenated and then sent
to printers so this is our hypothetical
example I know this is contrived in a
little silly but it'll give us something
to work with so how does this work so we
can create our a VB engine and say we
have a data frame that has our jobs we
have a color column and a printer column
we're gonna print color on our high
contrast printer and we can use that
engine to add CMYK columns that's very
nice we look at our data frame after
adding the columns and we see now we
have a column for each of CMY and K
finally we can submit our jobs to our
printers and our fantastic monochromatic
vinyl banners are printed and and we're
very excited so that's our scenario now
before we get into mutation we got to
take a tiny detour to understand a
little bit about color systems many of
you already know this
there's many parametric representations
for color there's RGB and CMYK RGB is as
screens project CMYK is as printers
print that you probably know you may not
know that printed black is not always a
hundred percent k printers can actually
add additional colors to the black to
get a richer or different black that's
just some context to frame what we're
gonna do here so let's look at the
implementation of this avb in panda so
what we're gonna do here again this is
extremely simple we're gonna have a data
frame that has as its index CMY and k
and we're going to populate columns for
colors so this is going to be our color
mapping that our engineers are going to
use now in practice we might have many
many many more colors here we're just
using four right now
so each of these values are CMY and k
and we have a utility method called add
CMYK columns which is going to go
through each of the cym and k and going
to populate a column on the past in
frame with the color for each component
so we're going to iterate over CMY and k
we're going to be
for each for each we're going to call
apply on the color series and we're
going to pull from the mapping just the
colors the CMYK n-- one at a time for
the color in the mapping this is the
road this is the column so this is how
this thing works
so we have our a VB engine we have our
map of colors we produce a jobs data
frame this has just one job we add our
CMYK columns and we're ready to go okay
so that's the basic tool that we're
going to describe here now we have two
engineers Tom and John and our two
engineers are both producing frames one
with green red and black and the other
with green blue and black and they are
targeting different printers so tom is
targeting a strong mid tone printer and
John is targeting a high contrast
printer they both add their CMYK columns
and they're done to get the results we
concatenate the two frames and we send
that to the printer and that gives us
what we expect so we have six jobs
queued up here for two different
printers both of them are using 100% k4
black so we find out that uh black was
insufficient so tom goes and he prints
his output and he finds out that on his
strong mid-tone printer the black is
insufficient so tom looks to the
internet to see if he can solve this
problem and he finds out that you can
use other types of black that you can
mix other colors into your black to get
a richer black a cool black a warm black
there's a whole menu of blacks so tom
does something quite natural he gets the
shared engine right here and he changes
black
he says black is going to be 60% cyan
60% magenta 40% yellow and 100% black
and he's gonna change that right there
and then his code he does have to change
any of his other code in fact this is
probably why he was motivated to do it
this way because he could just make this
one change and none of his code had to
change that's great what's gonna happen
to our results well Tom got the rich
black that he wanted but John also got
it John did not want the rich black in
fact he's using a high
contrast printer if he uses this rich
black it might over saturate the paper
and cause some sort of the vinyl and
cause some printing disaster so this is
not what we want this is mutation gone
astray so mutation of shared state is a
danger and a common source of bugs in
our code it leads to unintended side
effects it introduces order dependency
and it forces users to make defensive
copies which generally are inefficient
so how can we improve this with static
frame so here's the implementation of
the same thing now in static frame what
we're gonna do here is we're gonna start
with a mutable dictionary we're gonna
build up our mapping intermedia Bowl
dictionary and then we're going to put
that in a static frame frame object now
this is very much like our pandas
dataframe object but it is fixed in size
fixing columns fixed in rows and all of
the values are immutable the add CMYK
columns function is very similar it's
going to take in a frame geo this is the
grow only frame we're gonna add columns
to this frame so we need a grow only
frame and we're gonna do basically the
same thing notice that we don't have an
apply method we have an inner element on
the series method that then has an apply
function and we can apply the same
function to give us the values for each
column of C my and K so how does this
work well it looks pretty much the same
this is our first view of what a static
frame frame looks at and there's some
differences in how we present the frame
so if we look at this mapping now we see
a couple of differences we see that the
type of the frame the type of the index
columns and the index index is given and
the underlying numpy container type is
given as well the data type for the
contained in the numpy arrays so using
this it's pretty much the same user can
go and get a jobs frame geo and we can
see what that looks like there we can
add the jobs to we can pass the jobs
frame to the ad CMYK columns and get our
CMYK columns added to the frame so this
works pretty well let's see what happens
to Tom's code with this new approach so
tom as code hasn't changed pretty much
except for that he needed to update this
to be a frame geo he did that and he
wants to continue to use his rich black
so he doesn't change anything else and
he goes and runs his code and what
happens he gets an exception
you cannot mutate the frame he's trying
to add a column or mutated an existing
column and frame object does not support
item assignment he can't do it okay so
that's good for John in particular but
Tom is creative and will not stop there
so instead he tries to use an eye lock
call on the series given from the frame
and mutate that well that also produces
an exception there is no series mutation
we can't actually edit the values in the
series with an eye lock all now tom is
undeterred he knows that when he's used
pandas sometimes he knows that he can go
in there and mutate an underlying numpy
array and see that mutation in his
series or frame it's this kind of
sketchy backdoor and he really wants us
to work so he's gonna go and try and get
the values the actual numpy array from
the underlying theories and mutate that
value directly and he's sure this will
work but of course it does not because
our numpy arrays are immutable the value
ere the assignment destination is
read-only tells us that we cannot
actually mutate the values in the frame
so that's good fighting mutation is what
I want to do and static frame gives us a
way to do that now no approach in Python
is perfect but I believe that reasonable
barriers to doing bad things is good
these grow only structures that I've
shown here offer a sort of practical
compromise where we can append columns
the underlined numpy arrays are still
immutable but we can use some idioms
where we add columns and as I mentioned
that idiom is one that we use quite a
bit in my own work what's nice about
that is if we're appending or extending
arrays we do not have to copy them if
they're immutable so we've handled one
type of mutation we've handled a value
mutation that's going on in this
function but there's other types of
mutations there's mutations of the past
and argument and mutation of the
container that's being passed in so
let's get rid of those two so this is as
our implementation now stands we use a
static frame to hold the mapping this is
fixed in size and fixed in value and we
look at our ad CMYK columns function
here this is taking our frame geo and
we're adding columns to the past and
argument we're mutating our past in
argument and in the narrow case we have
here this might be acceptable but again
we know that mutation is the source of
heirs and this may lead to surprising
outcome so we can do better in this
alternative implementation the function
formerly known as ad CMYK columns
becomes get CMYK columns and we're gonna
pass it in not an entire frame but just
what we need just the colors represented
in an immutable series what we're going
to return is also an immutable frame
we're not going to add columns we're
just going to produce a new frame using
a generator right here which is going to
yield pairs of the CMYK code and the
array and we're gonna use that to build
our frame and a mutable frame that we're
going to return now this is actually
quite efficient because the immutable
numpy array that we create here can be
used in this frame without copying
because it's immutable we can just take
that frame we do not have to copy it as
we use it to build our frame which is
quite nice so designing with immutable
data gives us many benefits our function
arguments now expose minimal
dependencies we just pass what we need
functions never mutate their arguments
and functions return new and mutable
containers all of these things give
advantages to our overall architecture
ok so now for the client code user John
here he using this new approach where
he's not mutating his past in arguments
we'll take his data frame is a static
frame rather and has one frame for jobs
and another frame for CMYK value and
then he sent
concatenates them at the end so this
approach is much better than mutating
the past an argument this approach is
also efficient because with static frame
this concatenation assuming the indices
align this concatenation does not have
to copy underline data because the
underline and numpy arrays are immutable
they do not have to be copied in this
concatenation we can produce a new frame
that shares references to the underlying
data which gives us great opportunities
for efficiency
so architecture and mutability are
linked avoiding mutation leads to
different architectures architectures
are less error-prone when internal state
is not mutated functions do not mutate
their arguments and api's return handles
to immutable data and each of those
things we've done in the refactoring of
this code here now assignment is a
problem not just because assignment
causes mutation but because in pandas we
have this rich way of defining an
assignment we have these we can assign
to expressions for slices we can assign
to selection lists we can assign two
boolean arrays and this is quite
powerful and useful and I don't want to
give that up so we retain that interface
by avoiding mutation and we do it with
using function calls instead of the
assignment operator so if I want to use
the assignment like idiom here's my
original frame I want to assign to call
them C transformed version of column C I
don't use the assignment operator
I use this assign attribute I select
what I want and I pass in as a function
call the changed values which is what
I'm doing here and we get a new column
with scaled values so the assigned
attribute exposes the selection
interface and then provides a callable
that we pass in the value that we want
to change and we get out of this a new
frame now in some cases this could be
very inefficient but the static frame
will copy is little possible it will it
definitely has to change the column or
the values that we're mutating but other
components of the underlying managed
data do not have to be copied and can be
shared in the new frame that's returned
another example of this here we're using
an LOC call we're selecting
row II and columns see a slice of C to
the end and we're going to just assign a
new value there for the four colors and
we can see that we get a new frame with
those new values defined okay so we've
talked about immutability and why that's
such a key difference and why that was
really the key motivation for static
frame there's a number of other
differences which I'll go over more
quickly with static frame we have a goal
of having more narrow interfaces that
means removing redundancies and of
course does any Python reminds us that
there should be one and preferably only
one obvious way to do things and that's
a big part of what I mean by more narrow
interfaces we want to reduce function
parameters and favor more specialized
functions so we'll look at two small
examples of this and how static frame
deviates from pandas so in pandas you
can axe access a column here's our
initial data frame we can access a
column with the get item syntax we can
also access a column with an attribute
now I'm sure this was very convenient at
the time but this convenience is leads
to problems we can set a name attribute
on a data frame that's not a column of
course and get back that string we can
have a column name name and that's the
proper series what do we get if we do
engine map name I can't remember and
that's a problem get item is the similar
case so get item can be used as a column
selector generally we think of get item
as a column selector if we want to call
them we want to call them red we call
get item with the string red if we want
a row we generally use an LOC selection
we select row Y but get item can
sometimes be used as a row selector in
pandas if I provide just row indices to
the get item selector I'm not going to
get anything out that doesn't work but
if I happen to provide a boolean array
of size equal to the height of the table
this actually works I can actually
select rows out of the get item
interface this of course is redundant
with using an LOC call so in static
frame we strive to have consistent
specialized interfaces there's no
attribute access to columns you have to
use get item get item is only
column selector you can never get rose
out of get item dot lock is only a row
or row column pair selector this leads
to more numerous or narrow functions
with less parameter configuration okay
next up another important difference
between pandas and static frame is that
we enforce unique indices so in pandas
it has this really interesting feature
that I can take a frame and I can take a
column here the column blue which has
only two values for four rows and I can
set that as the index now that's really
interesting but I've never needed this
I've never needed this every time this
has happened this has been an air
something I've done wrong something I
did not want maybe others have
application for this but I've never
needed it you can disable it with the
verify integrity option but by default
this is false
I find that undesirable in static frame
index integrity is never optional so all
indices have to be unique next up is
deviations from numpy now the with
static frame again this is trying to be
a fairly lightweight package I don't
have opinions about the things that
numpy has already decided and I don't
want to create opinions for those things
so in numpy if we create an array of
single characters we get a single
character type in pandas if we created
rate of single characters we get an
object types now there's probably good
reasons for doing this if I want an
object type though I want to specify it
in static frame if we give a create an
array out of single characters we get a
single character type calculations
implemented in dump I also will deviate
sometimes from pandas so for in numpy
standard deviation of three numbers by
default gives you point eight one six if
you take a panda series and you take the
standard deviation of this you get 1.0
now it's no mystery why this is
different it happens to do with the
Delta degrees-of-freedom
argument being set to a different
default but I don't need a different
default I don't have an opinion about
what is the right default I'm happy to
rely on numpy for that so in static
frame we get the standard numpy default
for a standard deviation so in static
frame we try to stay relatively close to
numpy
now next up we have a static frame
exposes a whole range of specialized
iterators for function application so
looking at pandas we have a couple of
functions that allow us to iterate over
elements we can it arose we can inter
tuples we can do group by and we have a
number of functions for applying
functions to iterated values we have
apply map which iterates over individual
values on the table and we have apply
which we can use to iterate over rows or
columns we can change what apply
iterates and passes to functions with
this raw argument we can set it to false
to get series we can set it to true to
get a raise so with static frame we've
taken a completely different approach
with iterators and function application
the type is determined by the function
not by a parameter parameter the
iterated type has is given by a
different function either an element
array a named tuple or series and
iterating over values or items that is
key in value pairs is also distinguished
by function not by parameter we have
access arguments and iteration is
directly linked to function applications
so our iterators are used for function
applications they're perfectly tied
together which i think is also very nice
the cost of this is that we end up with
a ton of functions so we have in our
element we have inner array inner tupple
inner series and inner group so these
are the family of iterators on a frame
we know clearly what type we're going to
pass to our functions or what we're
going to get back out of these iterators
by the name of the function we have
another version of each of these
functions that is an item's version
which returns pairs of the index and the
array tuples series or whatever we want
to get out of these guys so to see an
example of this we can have our frame we
can inter series and we can get one
series out by x is 0 we can it array by
access one and get a nice array out of
this what's with this gets really nice
is when we apply functions to those
iterables so all these inner functions
return a powerful interface and each of
those interfaces has various apply
functions on them we can apply a
function we can use a multi processing
to do what's called a ply pool use
pythons multi-processing api's we can
get lazy generators of applications with
apply ater and apply it or items so we
can then use this here we're taking our
frame we're iterating over each element
and we're transforming the the floats
into strings and removing the zeros here
we see quite clearly that our function
application is applied to our iterators
those two things are always linked and I
think that's quite nice looking at a
more complex example if we want to
transform our CMYK values to RGB values
we can have a function that takes color
name tuples and returns the hexadecimal
string for that color so here's our
frame we call a turtle give it access
one and pass our function and we get a
series back with our hexadecimal values
so static frame exposes a whole family
of specialized iterators you can iterate
over just what you need you have
variable access for all iterators you
can get a series name couple or array
depending on what you need and what you
want to pay for you can enter values or
pairs and function application is always
linked to the iterator that's really the
key design choice here okay so I'm sure
by now you're wondering is static frame
as fast as pandas well the answer is
sometimes sometimes not right now static
frame is pure Python and numpy there is
no C libraries there's no scythe on
there's no number there's just Python
and numpy and our performance
evaluations to this point are very
narrow on isolated features it may not
be relevant to your work for your work
you need to look at the larger context
so these are artificial we will use the
ratio to pandas as a way to give us a
good benchmark so we're gonna look at a
couple examples using the following
environment so let's check these out so
here we have a uniformly typed array
sorry a uniform type frame of floats
we're gonna have 10 string indices we're
gonna have index of 10,000 values a
thousand columns and we're gonna have
random floats in there so we're gonna
create our frame we're gonna do some
function application and then we're
going to both by an array and by series
in this case we're going to select a
subset of columns and a subset of
indices I'm just as the static frame
code I'm not
showing you the corresponding pandas
code but it looks kind of similar so we
can see that our loading of the frame is
18 times slower that's a little sad but
a a function application is all very
good or if not sometimes better we see
some particular benefits so for example
concatenating subsets of that very large
frame here by taking two different
subset selections from the frame and
then concatenate them together here we
see a marked improvement over pandas and
that very likely is due to the that we
do not actually have to copy the
underlying data so with a mixed type
frame the results are a little bit
different so here I have a frame that's
built with combinations of random floats
and random integers can transform to
boolean and are going to produce a frame
of the same size with floats and
boolean's and alternating columns I'm
going to create that frame and then I'm
gonna take subsets and sum them up so
here static frame does very well
creation is about the same and our
subset selection is close or faster
finally data loading so here we're going
to get a very large CSV of traffic
incident data and we're gonna write that
to disk and we're gonna load that into a
frame in a static frame you do that with
a alternative constructor on the frame
class how do we do here not so good so
this takes seven eight seconds in pandas
113 seconds in static frame that is
painful so right now this is just pure
numpy this is a opportunity for
improvement we're just using numpy CSV
reader here which many of you know is
significantly slower than pandas so what
are alternatives well we can read JSON
data if we read JSON data here a modest
table from a JSON API we're actually
quite close to pandas and there's
another alternative if we just use
pandas to read the CSV and then use
static frames from pandas as a trick but
that gets us to nearly identical
performance so that's
opportunity for improvement but we'll
get there eventually so static frame is
definitely in alpha stage but it is
pretty useful the core functionality is
nearly complete we have releases and
documentation at the usual places we
have some issues on github that you can
check out static frame has been
developed within research affiliates
where we're dedicated to continued
development of this tool we have started
small scale integration of static frame
in limited applications and we're
starting case studies of large-scale use
of static frame our roadmap includes
working on input and output support so
that's really I think the next big thing
that we need to bring to static frame
including an implementation of from CSV
that is comparable to pandas there's
lots of opportunities for performance
tuning as I mentioned at this point
there is none and probably by a year
from now I think we might be ready for a
1.0 release with a stable API so we're
looking for contributors as many
projects are I encourage you all to try
it out find any issues implement some
features give me give us some
performance information I would be
fascinated to see what you guys find
before I conclude I have to acknowledge
the investment systems teams my
colleagues this I while I coded
nearly all of static frame I benefited
greatly from the review and commentary
of my colleagues and I also want to
point out that this was developed within
the context of open source development
at research affiliates my employer and
we've produced many interesting Python
packages which I encourage you guys to
check out so you can find our code on
github and I'm interested if any you
have any questions thank you
[Applause]
Thanks yes yes yeah yeah I I didn't
I forget how my performance is doing
there but I think we're kind of close I
think we're reasonably close yeah okay
great thank you collaborations